I've written extensively as a when I was
a law professor
[Music]
been a lot of University campuses matter
of fact for four years I was a full
professor at the University of
Pennsylvania here's a story that you
told at least three times about Nelson
Mandela take a look
for meeting him
for being arrested with our U.N
Ambassador on the streets of Soweto
trying to get to see him on Robbins
Island I guess the question is were you
confused or were you just trying to
embellish a story they think I'm kidding
man
seems like yesterday the first time I
got arrested anyway but I am a hard coal
miner anthracite coal Scranton
Pennsylvania hell I might be president
now if it weren't for the fact I said my
I had an uncle it was a coal miner
turned out I didn't have anybody in the
coal mines you know I mean really I
tried that crap you know my dad was not
a was he was a salesperson he wasn't a
coal miner my great-grandpop was but I
used to drive a tractor-trailer oh
awesome and so I know a little bit about
driving big trucks no that's great but
um
everybody I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report it is April 19 2023 we're
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals if you haven't joined us over on
locals yet
reubenreport.locals.com we do a live
post game show every day I answer your
questions you can correct me on errors
or other critical thing things that I
might have missed or mumbled through
much like Joe Biden and it's a good time
for all and you support us and keep us
independent and all that good stuff it
is a Reuben report first today because
that little video that we just showed
you right there that compilation that's
only half of it but I felt we couldn't
do like a two and a half minute cold
open so we split it and today's cold
close will just be an extension of the
cold open that has never happened before
in the history of the Reuben report but
we're keeping you on your toes and
today's theme I like this show today I
usually like the show but I really like
the theme today it's basically what the
high hell is going on here we seem to be
having physical and spiritual problems I
mean physical problems in that our
cities are rotting and I mean spiritual
problems in that our culture is melting
there are reasons for it I think a whole
bunch of us see it a whole bunch of us
are concerned about about it and I think
it is finally time for a whole bunch of
us to do something about it that is what
we will be unpacking as the kids say
today and before we do it let me talk to
you guys about ramp real quick do you
feel like your finance software isn't
cutting it do you want the latest and
greatest in financial software to simply
spend help you save time and keep you
from getting trapped in busy work check
out ramp ramp is the corporate card and
expense management software designed to
help you save time and put money back in
your pocket ramp gives Finance teams
unprecedented control and insight into
companies spend with ramp you're able to
issue cards to every employee with
limits and restrictions and automate
expense reporting so you can stop
wasting time at the end of every month
ramps accounting software automatically
collects receipts and categorizes your
expenses in real time so you don't have
to you'll never have to chase down a
receipt again and your employees will no
longer spend hours submitting expense
reports this the time you'll save each
month on employee expenses will allow
you to close your books eight times
faster ramp saves you money businesses
that use ramps save an average of 3.5
percent in the first year and now get
250 dollars when you join ramp just go
to ramp.com Reuben that's rampramp.com
Ruben and now back to me here we go
let's start
with the culture stuff right so one of
the things I've been doing for a while
on this show is we do we do the hardcore
politics what's going on with whoever
wants to be president what's happening
on the capitol all of the nitty-gritty
racehorse politics stuff but as Andrew
Breitbart said and has now become a I
would say a verbal meme uh politics is
Downstream from culture you can't win
the political Wars if you've lost the
culture meaning people will not even
understand what the real issues are you
will basically be trying to swim
yourself out of the La Brea Tar Pits
while you're always thinking because
you've lost the culture you have nothing
to stand on to actually fight the
political Wars properly so let's do a
little culture first my buddy Adam
sosnick who is one of the hosts over at
the Patrick Bet David podcast he talks a
lot about money but he also talks a lot
about dating and he did a video a couple
days ago talking about how so many women
right right now seem to be entering
their 30s and 40s unmarried and unhappy
well Chelsea Handler caught wind of that
and you know Chelsea Handler she is a
quote-unquote comedian mostly she seems
to me to be some sort of alcoholic
looking for attention but in any event
she saw the video of Adam talking about
with stats and actual factual
information how women are less married
in their 30s and 40s they're not having
kids as much and it's leading to a
mental health crisis and a happiness
crisis and a purpose crisis I mean this
is a lot of Jordan Peterson style stuff
anyway Chelsea saw the video of Adam and
she put this thing together I believe
this is on The Tick Tock is it on the
tick tock yeah on the tick tock
45 percent of working women ages 25 to
45 by 2030 will be non-married no kids
single
I'll tell you what's wrong with that
nothing I usually don't do things like
this but when I have to listen to men
talk like that I have no choice but to
sedate myself with drugs and alcohol
lately I've been loud and proud about my
status as a single unmarried childless
wild woman and apparently some men
cannot handle that every time I go on
Instagram I stumble upon sde morons like
this guy pontificating about how unhappy
women like me must be if you think that
you're going to be 45 years old no kids
not married and that you're gonna
genuinely be fulfilled in life because
you made money best of luck to you honey
right so best of luck to you honey I'm
sorry but if the child free Joyride I'm
on triggers you here's a hint if you
need Daily Alpha content to remind you
to be Alpha you might not be an alpha
take it from an alpha and the truth is
studies show that single women live
longer and are
you want to know why because they wake
up every day and they don't have to
listen to like you anyway I
have to go because my single unmarried
is about to perform at my sold out
comedy show I'd invite you but there are
no tickets left bye
man it's so interesting because there
there's really a lot here uh first off
Adam's going into some actual numbers on
this stuff and we're going to give you
some more numbers on this related to
depression and a bunch more uh but what
he what he says there is if you want to
have a genuinely be genuinely fulfilled
in life and the question there for
Chelsea and by the way I don't mean this
in a in a purely judgmental sense I
truly don't everyone is an individual
and there are people there absolutely
are people who who are outside of the
norm right so if 90 of people let's say
uh want the same things like
fundamentally actually want the same
things to find a partner that makes them
happy and be fulfilled and hopefully
have a family and experience all of
those things that's probably what ninety
percent of the people actually want if
you could just sort of parse it down but
of course there are people on the
margins who can be fulfilled in other
ways right you might find someone who is
the most brilliant artist or musician or
whatever that can that puts literally
everything into their life into that art
or or work or whatever it is and somehow
can create a community around that and
be fulfilled in every possible way but
those are margin cases for sure so it's
interesting because Adam's talking about
genuine fulfillment and then you have
Chelsea Handler and I get it she's
trying to be funny but pouring vodka in
the middle of the day talking about how
how she has a sold out show so yes her
ego will be fed as people applaud for
her and I say that with all due irony I
like doing shows where I get on stage
and people laugh and people applaud and
all of those things but the truth is is
that leading her and to not really make
it about her is that leading the average
woman
and I think this is more for women men
men can be distracted in all sorts of
ways but I think it is also for men uh
finding someone that you love that you
want to build a family with and a home
with and expand that to a community like
we all know that is fundamentally right
and and true and the most important
thing that there is so so there's this
weird disconnect where she's like I
don't have to pay attention to people
like you because I'm rich and people
love me but she is paying attention to
people like them uh Patrick David who is
uh sasnix on his uh show every day uh
said this on Twitter I thought this was
quite good childless women are 46 more
likely to report higher depression
compared to mothers some are childless
by choice some can't get pregnant people
who try so hard to appear Happy on the
outside are typically in a lot of pain
she's trying real hard now that's
obviously in reference to to Chelsea
Handler again again everyone has every
right to make every choice for
themselves I am not trying to uh to tell
anyone to live any way that they don't
want to but there are themes there are
basic truths that we all know to be true
and I think part of the reason we're so
screwed up culturally and politically
and everything else is everything that
we knew to be true 20 years ago seems to
be up for debate today and if you think
at the end of the day it would be better
for society to have more
alcoholic ego chasing 45 year old women
than women who say want to raise a
family and and be a good spouse and
hopefully the the male is a good spouse
too or if it's two men that's okay with
me too or two chicks or whatever it is
but the basic structure is the is is
obvious and true but let's shift a
little bit because that's just where I
wanted to start today because uh that's
the adult portion of this right but
there's a kids portion of this that we
are seeing the left has been coming
after kids and the genital stuff and the
gender stuff and all of that so they're
they're coming after adulthood in a way
right you see you see someone like
Chelsea trying to this is what culture
is promoting you should just do whatever
you want you should drink all day and
Chase whatever you want and don't get
married or get married much later or
only have one kid blah blah blah blah
blah as if any of these things leave you
fulfilled so they're coming for the kids
and now they are also coming for the
adults and this is a problem but
speaking of the kids because we cannot
do a show without some crazed Democrat
somewhere literally coming for
children's body parts this is this is
rather wild here is Democrat
representative Zoe Zephyr of Montana who
apparently happens to be trans telling
other Representatives well I'm not going
to lead it too much but basically they
passed a bill that would stop minor sex
surgery and she or he is not very happy
about it
the only thing I will say is if I if you
vote Yes on this bill
and yes on these amendments I hope the
next time there's an invocation when you
bow your heads in prayer you see the
blood on your hands
the blood on your hands now I don't know
if Zoe Zephyr knows what irony is but of
course the irony there would be if you
chop a child's genital off uh genitals
off you literally literally have blood
on your hands uh stopping people from
doing that activist doctors stopping
them from doing that to Children again
we're talking about children we're not
talking about an adult who makes a
decision for themselves a fully formed
brain making some decision and then the
adult saying this is how I wish to live
my life this is about children so yes
you would have blood on your hands if
you performed that type of surgery the
person who is stopping it is not the one
with blood on their hands but here we
are and it sort of never ends now
interestingly uh you know I often talk
to you guys about that Florida blueprint
that so much of the good stuff that is
happening across the country right now
related to a lot of the woke stuff
related to school choice etc etc is
emanating for first out of Florida and
then translating to other states so
they're pushing that through in Montana
right now and guess what if you don't
like that if you are a Montana parent
who desperately wants your
seven-year-old to be on puberty blockers
and puberty blockers and have their
genitals chopped off you can move to
California that's the beauty of the
Federalist system as you know but more
and more red states are taking the
blueprint of Florida and doing something
with it but here in Florida it is still
being debated we are we are actually
well the debate in essence is over but
you know the left never lets go of
anything so we have now passed a law
that will ban minor sex surgery for
children for children it is not
discriminating against any adult if you
are a trans adult and you live in
Florida you have every right that
everyone else has that so this
everything they say is nonsense you know
that but Florida house representative
one of the few Democrats that we have
here in Florida Anna eskmani uh here is
asking whether puberty blockers will be
available for kids once this new law
that Florida has just passed goes
through
thank you Mr Speaker but to be clear if
a doctor recommends puberty blockers or
home replacement therapy that is no
longer going to be available in the
State of Florida even in clinical trials
representative masulo
thank you Mr Speaker hopefully if this
bill becomes law yes representative
Escobar yes so sorry in Florida we are
saying enough is enough right that's
what I keep telling you all all you have
to do to be a good politician right now
or not even a politician all you have to
do to be a good citizen right now is
just say no I will not participate in
this lunacy anymore okay that's all you
have to do right now that's what
DeSantis is doing and now because of the
super majority he has we will not allow
for radical Lefty Progressive
Progressive doctors to give hormones to
children to stop their natural natural
biological processes and we will not
chop their genitals off this is called
good but she's not very happy about that
now if if your if her name rings a bell
you might remember this this is from my
event uh promoted this was the last show
that we were going to do on the big book
tour where Ron DeSantis Governor
DeSantis joined us in uh in Orlando and
she arranged a protest she wrote wow
super disappointed to see the Plaza Live
hosting an event with DeSantis next week
this is literally one of the most lgbtq
friendly parts of Orlando and during
pride month two orlandoins deserve
better than this culture War BS now
there's a whole level of irony as it
relates to me specifically there but she
basically was calling for the Plaza Live
the venue to cancel the show with me and
the governor now of course they did not
do that we sold out the show and for
those of you that have seen the full
event or that were there they arranged
what she did she protested at the event
so when DeSantis got on stage they had
set it up that they bought a bunch of
tickets and they were charging the stage
screaming all sorts of crazy stuff we
didn't let it stop the show we made
plenty of jokes at their expense
actually the Santa's dealt with it quite
well but she is apparently very upset if
a gay person talks to the governor
publicly if it's about the things that
she's not into she continued here is
Florida representative Bernie Jacques
asking her
if sexually explicit shows are okay for
children her answer is a little
confusing
do you think sexually explicit shows are
appropriate for children representative
escamani
thank you Mr Speaker again that's not
my amendment I don't have children the
there will be events that I will not
bring my children to if I had children
but it's not the government's job a
co-parent as many of our moms for
Liberty individuals say all the time and
so I just don't think it's appropriate
that I personally set that standard I
believe it or not y'all I can be a prune
sometimes I can be very conservative
person sometimes
um but again it's not me to judge or to
set a standard for others that's not why
I ran for office in the first place and
if we believe in the Free State of
Florida we should allow parents to make
those decisions especially since you
know it already works we already have
this standard and nothing terrible has
happened
it really is so incredible how how
mind-blowingly ridiculous progressives
are everything she said there is the
reverse of what progressives often say
she's saying it's not her job as a
government official to co-parent but
when parents come in to schools and say
oh we'd rather have our third graders
not learn how to give hand jobs they
freak out and they call it book Banning
right these are the people that are
completely for government control of
everything then when he she is asked
directly well do you think sexually
explicit material for children is okay
well I don't know I don't know about
that how would I know about that I don't
even have kids it is just incredible and
that's the thing when you when you
understand why
they have power they have power because
they have so controlled the cultural
apparatus and the corporate media and
everything else for so long that they're
idiotic really idiotic and backwards
ideas infected everything and they never
got any pushback on it that's why
they're trying to censor the internet
all the time that's why they're trying
to get Fox News canceled and take out
every counter voice because the
slightest bit of pushback exposes them
for the frauds that they are all he said
everyone knows you shouldn't be showing
sexually explicit material to kids right
everyone knows that that again this is
one of the things 20 years ago we did
not debate this it was done now they've
Unearthed this and her answer is well
the government isn't supposed to have
anything to do with educating your kids
and I don't even have kids in the first
place it is so
absolutely
[Music]
but let's continue on this thing we saw
this on I believe this is on MSNBC The
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC uh here is a South Beach so this
is a Miami drag queen her name or well
no it's not her drag queens for sure
drag queens are just dudes who dress up
like over-the-top women that's different
trans is I'm gonna do all this stuff to
my body and take all these hormones chop
my stuff off put on new stuff and live
as a woman drag queens are different
drag queens are just guys who dress up
like over the top ridiculous often very
scary women here is one by the name of
Tiffany Fantasia and he doesn't care for
kids that much so I guess that's nice
I mean listen this is a very big deal to
have you here this morning Tiffany thank
you so much for being here the state
bill it's 14 38. let's talk about what
it is it's an anti-drag measure it
passed in the Florida Senate this week
it would block anyone under the age of
18 even if accompanied by a parent from
being able to attend a drag show or a
parade which is absurd it would seek to
penalize any venue for valuations excuse
me violations we're talking ten thousand
dollar fines and possible jail time for
a drag show so what's your reaction to
this latest republican-led attack on
lgbtq community it is completely absurd
and unnecessary
um
although at the end of the day I don't
care for kids too much because they
still the show but
have the right to bring your child to a
drag show I mean what type of world are
we living in ladies and gentlemen this
is what oil I should say ladies and
gentlemen or miscellaneous this is what
passes as news on MSNBC finding a random
dude who dresses like a woman and then
asking them what their feelings are on
legislation and having that person
basically like I don't care about kids
MSNBC is a clown show okay that's fine
you get it I mean in that case literally
looks like a clown show I mean Jesus
with the makeup Lady dude whatever
um
look whether a parent uh
uh it's so stupid it's so stupid I
believe a parent should have autonomy
over what their children is seeing and
learning and everything else maybe I'm
feeling this topic specifically uh
passionately because I have two kids
downstairs and these kids it is so
obvious to me that when you look in
these kids eyes that it is your
responsibility as a parent to make sure
they aren't infected with with backwards
nonsense lies and it is a lie to say if
you are born biologically male that you
actually are a woman it is a lie to say
if you were born biologically female
that you are actually a man and it is
nobody else's certainly no state workers
responsibility to talk to those kids
about things that have that they have no
right to talk to them about but again
it's being pushed and pushed and pushed
and you go okay well that's just
cultural nonsense and nobody cares what
drag queens think and that's just one
trans legislator in Montana blah blah
blah but it works its way all the way up
through the culture well it's both ways
I think in some ways you can argue it
works all the way up and in some ways
you can work it works all the way down
but it works its way through the system
one way or another and then it affects
our politicians who then push policies
on us that nobody wants so as Governor
DeSantis here in Florida has taken away
Disney's special rights you guys know it
that's all he did he did not punish them
undeservingly he's not treating them
like like less than all he did was take
away special rights I thought everybody
was for equality right but as he has
done that the left is freaking out so
you remember Hillary Clinton does anyone
remember this woman she like ran for
president or saying she was Senator of
new York Secretary of State married to
Bill Clinton I'm pretty sure Bill
Clinton did not have sex with sexual
relations with that woman anyway here's
Hillary yesterday
as Republicans declare a war on Disney I
know whose side I'm on now I did respond
to that tweet and I asked where Bill's
other hand is because Daffy Donald
sorry Donald
um but it's so like this is just
ridiculous this is just what they do and
you know it gets all the thousands of
retweets and everything it's just
meaningless drivel no wait put the
picture back for a second because it's
funny to watch this picture like as
Republicans declare a war on Disney what
you're looking at there in Bill Clinton
Bill Clinton has been accused of rape by
about a dozen women he once took an
intern at the White House in the Oval
Office Monica Lewinsky she sat on his
lap while he stuck a cigar in her while
he was on the phone with Trent Lott I'm
sorry guys it's early but this is a fact
and uh and that's who she's standing
there with but it's Republicans who are
the bad guys he's he's such a family man
look at him with little Chelsea there
and everything else but she as
Republicans declare war on Disney so
what are you actually saying okay you
come back what are you actually saying
there Hillary you are for certain
corporations getting special benefits
you think that Disney should have its
own police force and it should have its
own special tax breaks that for some
reason Sea World and Universal Studios
don't get all he did was level the
playing field but you're seeing what
Democrats actually are and what they are
are the people who are for corporate
welfare when it's the corporations
pushing the nonsensical ideas that they
want Hillary and the lefties they need
Disney to push all of this crazy
psychosis on everybody because it's the
policies that they want to push forth so
that they can control more minds and
bodies
but ladies and gentlemen it is not
unfortunately just left Wingers coming
after DeSantis coming after it true
equality and all of these things it's a
bunch of weaklings and and patsies on
the right as well so check this out this
is former New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie now I think for the most part
I've I've always liked Chris Christie I
thought he was a decent guy when he was
running for president I thought he he
was would have been a decent candidate
uh probably could use a use a little uh
Weight Watchers or something but okay
fine uh but here he is going after
DeSantis because DeSantis took out
Disney's special privileges which I
thought again was what we would all want
everybody should be treated equally but
apparently not some Republicans
[Music]
conservative
I mean
you know where are we headed here now
um that if you express this agreement in
this country the government is allowed
to punish you
to me that's what I always thought
liberals did
and now all of a sudden here we are
participating in this with a republican
governor and this is absolutely
extraordinary absolutely extraordinary
if this whole battle had happened and
Disney had exactly was treated exactly
the same way as Sea World and any of
these other places Universal blah blah
blah Gator World Etc and then DeSantis
had started going after them and taking
away their equality meaning punishing
them in an extra way actually we're
going to Levy a special attacks on
Disney for this or we're going to charge
them more for the land that they're on
or whatever it might be that would be
punitive right that would be the problem
that Chris Christie is addressing there
but Chris Christie is addressing a
problem that does not exist all again
the scientists did until I'm blue in the
face was make Disney play the same way
with the same rules as everybody else so
what is this this thing that is
happening to I would say these Patsy
sort of Pat you on the head MSNBC
Republicans right these are the
romney-like Republicans they never do
anything to conserve anything but the
media kinda likes them right the media
kinda likes them because they're
Republicans who will never win and never
accomplish anything the media hates
DeSantis because not only is he winning
and accomplishing things he's also
ignoring them which that's a big problem
for them
um but you may remember I've referenced
this clip many times we've shown it to
you a couple times I just want to throw
it to you one more time Mike Pence a
couple weeks ago former VP Mike Pence on
CNBC basically saying the same thing
that Chris Christie is saying and it
just makes no sense to me
so we I fully support what Florida did
about protecting kids under the third
grade but I I have concerns about the
follow-on look Disney stepped into The
Fray they lost uh but then
they're taxing Authority I you know
that was that was beyond the scope of
what I as a conservative limited
government Republican would be prepared
to do
what are you talking about Mike Pence
why does Disney have taxing Authority
that's not in the Constitution or in the
Bill of Rights Corporation corporations
shouldn't have special treatment but you
really need to see this guys I know we
can bash the left all day long but this
brand of person on the right who doesn't
understand the basic ideas of
conservatism unless we're all anarchists
I think maybe what Chris Christie is
saying is I'm an anarchist I believe in
no laws at any point and the government
should never do anything about anything
it sounds like that's what Mike Pence is
saying as well uh Brian Griffin who
works for DeSantis uh who's a good dude
he had a great uh an extended tweet on
what this is all about he was talking
about Chris Christie he retweeted the
Chris Christie video that we just showed
you and he wrote this conservatism is
about good and limited government
individual empowerment and the rule of
law Disney had extraordinary special
privileges and then unfair special
Advantage compared to other businesses
in the state that is not appropriate
especially in light of Disney's threat
to work to overturn duly enacted
legislation in the State of Florida
legislation that empowered parents to be
involved in their child's education
which incidentally had extraordinary
public support after the Florida
legislature then acted to even the
playing field Disney attempted to make a
legally deficient 11th Hour agreement to
preserve their special privileges that's
an attempt to subvert the will of the
people of Florida and Governor DeSantis
will not stand for that good and limited
government and indeed principled
conservatism reduces special privilege
encourages an even playing field for
businesses and upholds the will of the
people in this fight Governor Ron
DeSantis is the champion of the people
of Florida I mean oh golf clap for you
right there Brian Griffin like that is
clear and clean and right and true right
he is explaining what limited government
is okay you don't want the government
doing and everything but you do want the
government making sure that there's an
even playing field he's also saying that
there is a difference
between conservatism and pure
libertarianism that there are moments
that the government is supposed to do
something so I think this is a really
important I know this may feel like a
little you know Florida Insider thing or
a little Disney thing or something but I
think it's a really important
ideological moment that as we roll into
this 2024 thing we're really going to
have to think about do you want to keep
supporting candidates that will let the
left come for virtually everything and
in the moments when they can push back
we'll be like well sorry we can't do
anything we're limited government guys
you know we can't really do anything
sure we can always figure out a way to
give Ukraine 100 billion dollars but you
know when the when the corporations are
coming for your kids and indoctrinating
them and when they're subverting the
will of the people who voted a super
majority in a landslide election for the
governor I don't want to touch that
we have to make that decision guys and
again I think this gets to why everybody
whether it's MSNBC or Chris Christie or
Mike Pence or Donald Trump are attacking
DeSantis he is the one most effective
guy doing any of this stuff and that is
the threat selling nfts on Instagram and
ranting and raving about election fraud
is not the threat the guy who's actually
accomplishing the things that we ask for
that actually is the threat so how does
this left-wing political ideology not
only lead us to a decaying culture right
if we're talking about all of the the
women the Chelsea Handler types who are
celebrating something that we know is
not quite right uh to the infection of
young children's minds and bodies but
also physically to our cities what is
happening in our cities well over the
last couple days there have been massive
crazy riots in Chicago now you know
about Chicago Chicago you know like a
dozen or so black people are killed
every weekend but nobody talks about it
because the shooters are black and that
doesn't really compute for CNN or
Washington Post or New York Times or
anything else and if you do bring it up
they somehow call you racist well
Chicago did do one decent thing for
about 27 seconds which was that they got
rid of far left lunatic Lori Lightfoot
but then 27 seconds later they elected
an even further left nut job and they
are now in an absolute state of chaos so
first off here is Lori Lightfoot now
former mayor Lori Lightfoot commenting
on the absolute Mayhem in Chicago over
the last couple days although she
doesn't quite think it's Mayhem
but on a very specific statement after a
morning event at the Chicago Public
Library outgoing mayor Lori Lightfoot
was asked about the Saturday night chaos
downtown that led to two people shot 15
arrested traffic disrupted and the CTA
suspending service into the loop
Lightfoot says there is lots of
opportunity to redirect young people to
Safe spaces but scoffed at one reporter
describing what happened as quote Mayhem
and here's the thing the mass majority
of the young people that came downtown
came downtown because it was a great
weather and an opportunity to enjoy the
city that's absolutely entirely
appropriate there are a few that came
with different intentions and they have
they have and they will be dealt with
but I'm not going to use your language
which I think is
um wrong to say that as man and I am so
sick of these people gaslighting us you
see the videos of hundreds of young
people jumping on buses twerking in cops
faces breaking Windows Rampage through
Walmart
etc etc I'm not going to use your
language of Mayhem we're just going to
get lost in some linguistic nonsense
enough is enough first off I just want
to tell you if you live in Chicago leave
you must leave I'm sorry I know Wrigley
Field is cool I've been there all right
it's cool go there one more time and
then get the hell out you gotta go deep
dish pizza frankly not that great let's
get you a New York slice okay even in
Miami I would argue the pizza is better
than Chicago I know I'm going to get a
lot of hate for that one but the chances
that you get shot while getting pizza in
Miami far less than if you were getting
pizza deep dish or otherwise in Chicago
but they Gaslight you right she because
of defunding the police and all of the
nonsense that she pushed she was booted
out of office they then elect someone
just as bad if not worse than her then
immediately you start getting these
rights and she's lost in whether we can
call it mayhem or not as they're mauling
people I mean there were some other
videos that were quite graphic a white
woman being attacked by about 50 black
kids uh but uh you know again that's not
something you're going to see on CNN
tonight but it's not just Chicago right
New York City is also in absolute free
fall and they're not doing anything
about it Eric Adams who was brought in
because they thought he was going to be
the same guy after communist Bill de
Blasio he has systematically destroyed
New York City check out the amount of
police officers that are leaving now and
that they've had to literally lower the
standards the physical and mental
standards for people to join the NYPD
because no smart young equipped person
wants to join the NYPD when the
administration is actively working
against you so the house Judiciary
Committee because Eric Adams isn't doing
anything in New York City they're having
hearings about what's going on in New
York City uh Eric Adams is not too happy
about that
why let's bring in the mayor of New York
City Eric Adams by the way what do you
think of this field Hearing in your city
about hmm crime I think is the highest
level of hypocrisy we know that cities
all across America are dealing with the
issues around Public Safety particularly
the criminal justice system and right in
the largest city in Ohio I was reported
today in one of the tabloids the murders
of over 50 in the first quarter and so
while crime is going down homicides are
going down here Shooters are going down
here some of the major uh crimes you're
trending in the right direction our
subway system crime is going down so I
think coming here and highlighting D.A
brag it's just really a political stunt
complete nonsense complete nonsense now
he is right that homicides have gone
slightly down we covered those numbers
over the last couple days because things
were so out of control during coven so
the numbers all the numbers related to
all of these things are slightly skewed
but I would welcome any of you to go to
New York City I don't recommend it I
would welcome you to do it I don't
recommend it go to New York City and see
how it feels when I have been back after
spending most of my formative years most
of my 20s and 30s in New York City it is
a zombie of a city no more business
people no more guys in suits wandering
around Midtown it's a whole bunch of
people as I keep saying either looking
for weed or selling weed or looking for
somebody to buy weed from or something
something that's basically what's going
on in New York City you cannot how could
imagine
imagine if you were uh uh you you you
had you sold t-shirts just anything you
were just like you know what I'm going
to open a brick and mortar store in New
York City whether it's down in SoHo or
on the upper east side or in Midtown I'm
going to open up a store with a nice big
window up front show off my great
t-shirts first off because of taxes and
regulation you just never do it in New
York City it's almost impossible to open
a business but also you know at any
moment mobs can just Rampage through and
nobody is going to do anything to stop
them also this idea that just because
homicides went down a tiny bit that
that's an indication of anything is
really not true there are other things
you know I did the Patrick bat David
podcast the live podcast with Rudy
Giuliani a couple weeks ago one of the
things that Rudy talked about is when
the city was in free fall when he came
in
in the 90s after four years of far left
Democrat Progressive David Dinkins being
in charge and the city was just Times
Square was just prostitutes everywhere
drugs everywhere blah blah blah the
first thing that he did was clean up the
basic crimes the guys that would if you
were driving in the bridge and tunnel
people you're coming in from Long Island
you're coming in from New Jersey
Westchester Etc you'd get on the other
side of the bridge like the Midtown
Tunnel for example coming in from Long
Island and there used to be all these
guys these panhandlers out there begging
you for money or guys that would take
wet newspapers to try to wash your
window with dirty water so that you'd
give them a dime he got rid of all of
them immediately because he wanted
people from outside of the city to come
in and not immediately be assaulted and
then that started allowing more people
to come in then he started cleaning up
cleaning up Times Square so the Disney
application of Times Square that you now
know which was good for a while and
putting aside all the other Disney stuff
it got rid of all the prostitutes and
the sex shops blah blah blah and then
you had a functioning 20-year run
between Giuliani and Mike Bloomberg
where New York City was absolutely
flourishing and it was not what Bill de
Blasio and Eric Adams have done to New
York but it but the point is that it's
not just about oh our our homicides went
down one or two percent that's not
really it it's not that the average
person is necessarily worried if they're
going to be murdered on the street
although they should be it's how many
homeless people are out there what's the
General State Of Mayhem that is allowed
and the Decay and all of those things
and just garbage cans overflowed and all
of those things and and then I'll move
on the fact that so many people who were
good functioning decent citizens paying
taxes and everything else and bringing
good culture to the city and going to
Lincoln Center and going to shows and
all of those things they've left so you
got a problem on your hand and guess
what guys this is this was the point of
all this even some long time Democrats
are realizing it here is Democrat city
councilman Robert Holden to talking
about how bad it has gotten in New York
71 years I've lived in New York City
I've seen bad times high crime 2 000
murders a year in the 80s I've not seen
the lawlessness that I'm seeing today in
New York City in my lifetime that means
we're afraid to go anywhere guys he's a
Democrat 71 years in New York City a
Democrat I've never seen it like this so
which do you think he's just a liar like
is he just absolutely lying are the
videos that you see all the time are
they just fabricated nonsense
or is it that Eric Adams is lying right
like which one is it you just have to
pick one and I think you guys know which
one probably is true and you know it's
probably true because of the policies
that uh DA's District Attorneys like
Alvin Bragg who's going after Donald
Trump in a I would argue a criminal
fashion uh he refuses to prosecute real
criminals here's uh representative Jim
Jordan talking about that
I mean think about this fact
327 individuals have done 6 000 of the
theft crimes in the city yeah I mean
they call them theft crimes we used to
call it stealing taking other people's
property so 300 and some people 327
people six now that's that's 20 arrests
but that's 20 times that each of these
individuals have done this on average
well maybe lock them up after the first
or the second or maybe the 19th time so
they don't do it the 20th time but
that's what's going on here and in
cities all over the country and it's why
what was the set I think I saw on on
your show last week where it sounded
like 27 percent of New Yorkers want to
move out of the state they want to move
out of here and it's driven by this
crime Factor
so Jim Jordan is painting this problem
with a really simple paintbrush guys
small minority of people are responsible
for a huge majority of the crime how
about we get them but the problem is
that the left actually believes Eric
Adams all of these people Lori Lightfoot
Etc et cetera they believe that the
criminals aren't the problem and I
really believe that they believe that
the system is the problem the criminal
is just a symptom it's the system of
capitalism and the patriarchy and blah
blah blah that lead these people to Maul
people on the streets and push Asian
women into Subways and burn down Pep
Boys and loot targets and everything
else so they they actually have more
Sympathy for the criminal than they have
for the victims of their criminal
Behavior so the question is what does
the left believe the root cause is right
what what do they actually think it is
this this Decay not only of our minds
related to gender and what actually
makes us fulfilled like family that sort
of thing but also to the decay in our
cities uh well they are always
distracted by other nonsense which is
why they can't get to those simple
answers that I'm laying out here so what
else while his city is in free fall what
else is Eric Adams declaring war on
about food
one in every five metric tons of carbon
dioxide our city emits comes from food
but all food is not created equal
the vast majority majority of food that
is contributed to our emission crises
lies and meat and dairy products we
already know that they plant plant power
diet is better for your physical and
mental health and I am living proof of
that but the reality is that thanks to
this new inventory we're finding out it
is better for the planet
grew you Eric Adams
even if everything you said there is
true which none of it is true right none
of it is true but even if it was you
have no right to tell people what they
are allowed to eat I love meat and I
will continue to eat meat and I live in
the Free State of Florida and you have
nothing to do with my life thankfully
but again if you live in New York if you
live in any of these places do you not
see the writing on the wall they are
coming for what you can eat and they're
also coming for how you can cook it gas
stoves there is nothing that you have
that they will not come for okay there
is also no evidence that a plant-based
diet is more healthy right there are
plenty of there's actually plenty of
evidence that carnivore-based diets are
more healthy or paleo diets are more
healthy or a whole bunch more but again
you have a right to eat all of the bad
crap that you want it is your god-given
right to live your life as you see fit
but they don't believe that they don't
believe that any of the basics of this
country are true that economy means
anything that individual rights mean
anything so one day in New York City
they will just have mobs of stone
zombies rampaging through everything
they will they will be going up to the
Upper East Side and pulling people out
by their hair from their luxury condos
because they are eating steak they'll be
doing it like Gangs of New York and well
I'll be here in Florida so I guess it'll
be okay again get out of New York if
you're there so what else of course
besides meat and dairy as you eat bugs
what else is the root cause of the decay
of our cities well obviously it's racism
right it's got to be right you can't
just be meat and dairy that are causing
the problems you gotta sprinkle in a
little racism on top like salt and
pepper
here's gay Pete our transportation
secretary who was completely unqualified
for the job except that he happened to
be married to a man that seems like you
might know more about roads why uh
here's gay Pete talking about how
roadway fatalities are uh racist
we've got a crisis when it comes to
roadway fatalities in America we lose
about 40
000 people every year it's a level
that's comparable to gun violence and we
see a lot of racial disparities black
and brown Americans tribal citizens and
Rural residents much more likely to lose
their lives whether it's in a car or as
a pedestrian being hit by a car there
are a lot of reasons related to
discrimination related to the even the
ways that roads are designed and built
who has access to a safe Street design
that's got crosswalks and good lighting
who doesn't have that access that can
drive disparities and we have a
responsibility to act on that first off
what the hell is happening to Al
Sharpton his head is shrinking like in
Beetlejuice at the end what is going on
there you know I know he used to be big
and fat but something about the
shrinkage of his whole body shrunk but
now the head is fine uh Pete yes our
roads are racist there's a disparity in
the amount of black people and tribal
citizens that's a new one tribal
citizens who are getting hit by cars or
something you know also there are
cultural reasons that people behave
differently there it might be I'm just
tossing this out there because they
Whittle everything down to racism and
like oh there must be a white guy trying
to plow down a whole bunch of black
people in a car and that somehow you
know is the thing that we should be
focusing on you know cultures all act
differently some people wear seat belts
it's taught more in certain communities
I'm not even saying that specifically
with all this but like every they just
Whittle everything down to the dumbest
possible lowest common denominator that
it is racist and really in essence what
he's saying is he wants equity and debt
and what that really means is you if you
think this guy can fix anything you're a
fool I mean has never accomplished
anything other than using his Democrat
privilege failing at things and moving
all the way up that's what he's really
good at okay uh but if you think they
can fix anything they can't and not only
that equity and death when so when he's
saying well black and brown brown people
and what was it tribal citizens uh they
are affected by this more what he really
means is we need more white people to
die because if then we had at least we
had the equity of death or at least more
white people were being hit by cars or
wearing less seat belts then apparently
he would be happy I know that sounds a
little nuts but that really is the truth
if he got a report
think about it when he gets these
reports and he looks at these reports
and they say well you know it does turn
out that more black and brown people
were hit by cars this month his initial
thing is oh the roads are racist right
but if he got a report and the report
said you know you're not going to
believe this gay Pete but it turns out
that we got 33 black and brown people
killed by hit by cars 33 tribal citizens
and 33 percent of white people well I
guess by his own logic he'd be like all
right that's pretty good you guys want
to go on vacation
guys so what do we say what do we do to
fix this cultural and physical decay in
our society well you know you know
because you're a you're a wise wise
person you watch the Reuben report you
know what you do you tell the truth
about what's going on you don't let them
just lie over and over without being
called out and mocked and you fight for
the things that are right and just and
are true and the things that we always
knew to be true like autonomy over your
own life and body like the importance of
family and community and things like
that the and also
call out the never-ending desire for
these people to have every bit of
control over your body this is really
good so this is a black activist I would
say an activist who happens to be Black
by the name of Bob Woodson on the Dr
Phil show talking about what has
happened in the black community and how
it relates to basically everything we're
talking about here today
if you dissect it you'll find there were
about
3700 free bikes who own 12 000 slaves
black slaves the question is
do the descendants of those free blacks
who own black slave do they pay blacks
really uh benefited more the first
hundred years after slavery we have in
the last 50 years I was born in 1937
during the Depression
everyone in my small low-income black
community
98 of the households had a man and a
woman raising children
elderly people could walk safely in that
Community without fear of being
assaulted by their grandchildren never
heard a gunfire during that time never
heard of a child being shot to death in
the crib
but their 50 children today who have
been shot until in our cities if you
talk you talk about remedies we've got
to look Beyond of saying that that every
solution has to have a a winner and a
loser that blacks can only benefit if
whites lose we have to be defined more
than just victims of Oppression what
makes more sense what that man is saying
or what you hear out of Lori Lightfoot
or Pete bootage or Joe Biden
or Chelsea Handler or any of these
people right because these things again
they are all connected the Chelsea
Handler I I am just going to be this
person who exists in Perpetual childhood
that will lead to a society that would
give us all of these problems these
things are not disconnected so who is
making more sense there right and what
do I always say about the the ability
when you are telling the truth you don't
have to be genuflecting and screaming
and throwing things all over the place
you can actually do it quite clearly
like Bob Woodson said right there you
know it's interesting when he mentioned
the last 50 years how much worse it's
gotten you know that basically is since
affirmative action that is since these
giant government programs and handouts
that have disproportionately affected
the black family so the rates of divorce
in black families were significantly
lower than whites before all of these
programs then they incentivized people
to have women to have more and more
children out of wedlock because you
would get more and more benefits do you
think that has something to do with
what's going on here and then when you
have a whole bunch a gen a giant
generation that grows up without fathers
and proper Role Models I mean you guys
get it this is Larry Elder stuff this is
Thomas Soul Stuff Etc so
look what do we do what do we do whether
you're fighting Chelsea handlers
nonsense right like if you're if you're
watching this right now and you're the
mother of a young girl how do you want
your daughter to turn out do you want
her to be a 50 something year old person
who seemingly only cares about ego and
alcohol
uh or do you want her to grow up to be
somebody that maybe will have a family
that will hopefully try to be a good
member of the community and all that
stuff and again I don't really mean to
make this specifically about Chelsea
Handler I'm using the idea of what she's
talking about okay even though I'm
pretty sure she called me racist on
Twitter at least once
um so what do we do we have to enact
virtue not Vice and I think we can do it
but it starts with you like you got to
figure out like what do you want to have
in this world one thing that could be
good that the left really hates uh is
have a big family have more kids and
show them the path that is that is kind
of good and that might be good here's
Scott Galloway on Real Time with Bill
Maher talking about just that
I'm down with it and you know what I
want grandkids
I think that my advice to any young
person is that
um okay it costs a third of a million
dollars to have a kid we've made it
increasingly hard we've made it
expensive for families to have kids
people say they don't want kids I don't
think that's true I think they can't
afford to have them and my advice to
every young person I know a lot of young
people watch this show is that for me I
did like you I did not want to have kids
having kids has been absolutely the best
thing I could have done that ruined my
life have kids
uh Scott Galloway is a marketing
professor at NYU School of Business the
stern School of Business but he's saying
again something that we all know to be
true and as long as we're talking about
things that are said that we all know to
be true that gives me a fine segue to
throw to Jordan Peterson
we talked a little bit about this uh
over a drink we had a couple weeks ago
but what about the couples that have no
kids couples that just say you know
we're more interested in our
intellectual Pursuits or traveling or
something you think they are really
missing sort of like a key component of
of what life is right I do I really
believe that I mean I think they don't I
think that kids have a bad rap that's
the problem and so they're very funny
they're really playful they really
really like you and you can have the
kind of relationship with them that you
set out to have
and so that's very very interesting now
and you can also like once I had little
kids I spent a lot more time with them
than I did with my friends say and the
reason for that was that
I actually found it more enjoyable to do
things with little kids than with the
adults and the reason for that is like
by the time you're 30 say
you've seen so much of the world that
you actually don't see the world anymore
and this is technically true the thing
that's cool about having a little kid is
everywhere you go because we're so good
at putting ourselves in other people's
bodies
the kid revitalizes the world and the
kids like oh
I mean that's what a two-year-old looks
like all the time right they're just
completely awe struck by everything and
you can see that again and that's really
interesting
and that's really interesting guys
that's 2017. I had really just it was in
the nases of my relationship and
friendship and camaraderie with Jordan
Peterson it was before we toured uh
subsequently I have two kids my life is
more fulfilled I heard that message also
it somehow made my beard darker I don't
know how that happened pretty cool
um so there are things that we know to
be true I'm living it now on a daily
basis when I'm waking up in the morning
and I think it's counter to almost
everything that is being pushed on us
culturally
you got to figure out how you're going
to incorporate that into your life so
that your life is in order so that you
can then hopefully set some of this
cultural and political stuff in order
and I just believe we can do it and it's
not all political but it is all
important
that is our show for today if you have
not subscribed yet on Rumble please jump
over there and do it our Rumble numbers
have been absolutely fantastic some of
the live streams are now passing YouTube
which is awesome considering you know
I've been on YouTube for about 10 years
and Rumble for about six months so it's
rumble.com reubenreport if you want to
join us right now we've got a live q a
and post game show at
reubenreport.locals.com my full episode
with Kat temp from Fox News Greg Gutfeld
Sidekick is up right now we leave you
with the second half of our cold open
Joe Biden just lying about a whole bunch
of stuff and I'll see everybody else uh
in just a minute
and Corn Pop was a bad dude
and he ran a bunch of bad boys and it's
in God's truth my word is abiding uh he
lied to voters according to the New York
Times uh quoting AIDS of bidens about
having marched in the Civil Rights
Movement advisers had gently reminded Mr
Biden of the problem with this
formulation he had not actually marched
during the Civil Rights Movement and
more than once Mr Biden assured them
that he understood and kept telling the
story anyway that is really really weird
and I'm not saying I am black but I want
to tell you something I I got started
out of an HBCU Delaware state now I
don't want to hear anything negative
about Delaware State here okay I was
sort of raised in the Puerto Rican
community at home that I quoted Robert
Kennedy without attributing to Robert
Kennedy I should have said to paraphrase
Neil kinnick to Biden used five pages of
published larva articles of eight
published Larry the article without
quotation or citation that's precisely
right and I've done some dumb things now
do dumb things again that's why I had so
damn in the other people I grew up have
cancer
[Music]
foreign